E
DEANGELIS AND PETE HEGSETH.
WE BEGIN WITH FOX NEWS ALERT ON
THE LATEST INSTANCE AGAINST
POLICE IN AMERICA.
STATE POLICE SAY THAT THEY WERE
LURED TO AN AMBUSH BY A FAKE 911
CALL.
35-YEAR-OLD POLICE SERGEANT
DUSTIN DELMONTE, FATHER OF TWO
WITH ANOTHER CHILD ON THE WAY.
HE WAS A 2019 OFFICER OF THE
YEAR, SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
AND AN ADVISOR FOR THE EXPLORER
CADET PROGRAM.
ALSO KILLED IN THE GUNFIRE, A
35-YEAR-OLD OFFICER WHO LEAVES
BEHIND A WIFE.
THE OFFICER WAS ALSO AN ADVISOR
TO THE CADET PROGRAM.
HEARTBREAKINGLY WE HAVE ANOTHER
SHOOTING IN RALEIGH,
NORTH CAROLINA, TO TELL YOU
ABOUT WHERE FIVE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN KILLED INCLUDING AN
OFF-DUTY POLICE OFFICER.
29-YEAR-OLD GABRIEL TORRES,
AFTER A GUNMAN WHO WAS JUST
15 YEARS OLD, OPENED FIRE
YESTERDAY ALONG A WALKING TRAIL
WITH AT LEAST TWO OTHERS WOUNDED
CRITICALLY.
THE SUSPECT WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY AND IS IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
BEFORE LAST NIGHT'S HORRIFIC
SHOOTING THE FRATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE TWEETING "SINCE MONDAY,
AT LEAST 12 POLICE OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN SHOT.
THE SPEWING OF ANTI-POLICE
RHETORIC AND THE FAILED POLICIES
OF PROSECUTORS AND JUDGES ARE
PLACING OUR OFFICERS IN GREATER
DANGER.
THE CULTURE OF LAWLESSNESS MUST
STOP."
PETE HEGSETH, I DON'T THINK
ANYONE COULD'VE SAID IT BETTER
OR MORE CLEARLY.
>> Pete: YOUR RIGHT AND I
COULD HEAR THE PASSION IN YOUR
VOICE WHEN YOU WERE SAYING IT.
WE HAVE THE FACES ON THE WALL.
WE HAD ONE SIDE OF THE POLITICAL
AISLE FOR YEARS TELLING THE
COUNTRY THAT THOSE GUYS RIGHT
THERE WERE THE BAD GUYS.
THEY ARE THE BAD GUYS.
THEY ARE THE PROBLEM.
WE NEED LESS OF THEM.
WHEN YOU CREATE THAT TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT, THEN CERTAIN TYPES
OF PEOPLE START TO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S OKAY TO DISPENSE WITH THOSE
LIES, TO CHALLENGE THEM, TO TELL
THEIR KIDS THAT THEY ARE THE BAD
GUYS, THAT'S WHAT A CULTURE OF
LAWLESSNESS LOOKS LIKE SO YOU
HAVE THE CULTURE NATIONALLY WITH
DEMOCRATS AND LEFTISTS HAVE
FOSTERED INTENTIONALLY AFTER
TRAGEDIES THAT OCCURRED.
THEN YOU HAVE CULTURES INSIDE
DEPARTMENTS.
I HAVE HAD GOOD MILITARY LEADERS
AND BAD MILITARY LEADERS.
WE HAVE SCARED POLICE DEPARTMENT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS THAT WOULD
THROW THEM UNDER THE BUS AND TEN
SECONDS WHICH MAKES EVERYONE OF
THEIR JOBS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
AND EVEN MORE DANGEROUS.
>> Emily: ISN'T THE ROLE OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS, FIGURES IN
OUR COUNTRY WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO
REPRESENT ALL AMERICANS, ISN'T
THEIR ROLE TO QUELL FULL
MENTATION, TO DISPEL OF RISING
TEMPERATURES IN SOME WAY TO
REPRESENT COOLING THE FIRE
RATHER THAN ADDING ONTO THE FIRE
WHICH WE'VE BEEN SUBJECTED TO,
AS PETE SAID, FOR OVER TWO
YEARS.
>> Kayleigh: A LOT OF THOSE
PROTESTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN UP
BY MAYORS, IT CAN SEEM COOL.
SO THEY CAN PACIFIED THE
PROGRESSIVE LEFT BUT PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN CITIES THAT BEEN OVERRUN
WITH CRIME AND HOMELESSNESS, YOU
LOOK AROUND AND YOU HOPE AT SOME
POINT VOTERS GO, THIS WAY IS NOT
WORKING.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, BECAUSE
IT IS THE MIRRORS WHO ARE THE
BRIDGE BETWEEN THE DAs AND THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
THERE'S A TOTAL DISCONNECT OF
POLICE DEPARTMENTS FEELING
COMPLETELY UNSUPPORTED.
WHO WOULD WANT TO BE A COP RIGHT
NOW?
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED GOOD
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
WE NEED PEOPLE INVESTED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WHO WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
WHO WANT THEIR CITIES TO BE
AWESOME.
WE ARE NOT GETTING THAT BECAUSE
THE MAYORS HAVE TURNED THEIR
BACKS ON THESE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE DAs ARE
RUNNING THE SHOW.
GUESS WHAT, THEY ARE RUNNING
CITIES INTO THE GROUND AND IT IS
SQUARELY AT THEIR FEET.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT.
KAYLEIGH, TRAGEDY UPON TRAGEDY
IS HOW PREVENTABLE THESE DEPTHS
ARE.
THEY COULD'VE BEEN PREVENTED.
AMBUSHES ARE UP NATIONALLY OVER
300%.
EVERY DAY WE REPORT ON THE
HORRIFIC NATURE OF A SHOOTING OR
A DEATH AND THEY ARE NOT
STATISTICS TO US.
THEY ARE INDIVIDUALS TO THEIR
FAMILY SENT TO US.
SO MANY NONPROFITS DEDICATED THE
FAMILIES OF THE FALLEN.
THE DETECTIVE RAFAEL RAYMO'S
FOUNDATION.
TROOPERS UNITED HOW MANY MORE
HAVE TO BE FOUNDED BY WIDOWS AND
FAMILY SUBJECTED TO WHAT IS
FINAL.
WE CAN'T GO BACK.
THESE POLITICIANS CAN GO BACK ON
THEIR WORD AND SAY I HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS
WHOLE TIME BUT IT CAN'T BE
REVERSED.
THE LOSS OF A POLICE OFFICER IN
THE LINE OF DUTY.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Kayleigh: YOU ARE RIGHT.
NOT STATISTICS, NONMEMBERS.
50 OFFICERS KILLED THIS YEAR
ALONE BY GUNFIRE.
50 LIVES CHANGED.
50 FAMILIES THEY DON'T HAVE
FATHERS OR MOTHERS OR SISTERS OR
BROTHERS.
EMILY, I KNOW YOU PROBABLY HEAR
ABOUT THIS IN YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
ALL OF US ON THIS COUCH.
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS AND
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES, I AM
HILLSBORO MANATEE COUNTY.
THOSE COUNTIES, POLK COUNTY
FLORIDA.
SHERIFF, BLAINE LANE, 21 YEARS
OLD, HE GOES TO SERVE A FELONY
WARRANT, A WOMAN WHO HAD 11
FELONIES, FOUR MISDEMEANORS.
THE SHOOT-OUT BEGAN BECAUSE SHE
POINTED A GUN AT THESE OFFICERS,
IT WAS A BB GUN.
HE DIED OF FRIENDLY FIRE IN A
SITUATION THAT HAVE NEVER
RESULTED IN GUNFIRE.
A LEAGUE LATER ANOTHER OFFICER,
HIS NAME WAS TONY NUNEZ.
SAME COUNTY.
SHOCK.
THIS TURNED OUT DIFFERENTLY.
HE HAD A BULLETPROOF VEST ON AND
THE BULLET WAS STOPPED BY THE
VEST ON THE ST. MICHAEL NECKLACE
HE WORE EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
WORK.
THESE ARE TWO STORIES JUST IN MY
LOCAL COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE
HAPPENING NATIONWIDE.
WE HAD A POLITICAL PARTY THAT
PERPETUATED THE ANTI-COP
NARRATIVE.
I KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT SAYS
WE ARE NOT FOR DEFUND THE
POLICE.
GET CORI BUSH IN LINE WHO WAS
ASKED IF SHE SUPPORTS IT.
SHE SAID YES ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT
SHE SAID WE SUPPORTED.
MR. PRESIDENT, CALL YOUR MEMBERS
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
PRETTY POWERFUL PLACE.
LOOK AT THEM AND SAY DONE WITH
THIS.
ENOUGH OFFICERS HAVE DIED.
>> Emily: CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG I'VE YET TO HEAR FROM OUR
NATIONS PRESIDENT OR
VICE PRESIDENT THIS WEEK ON THIS
TRAGIC STATISTIC.
272 SHOT.
JACKIE, IN ADDITION TO
EVERYTHING MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID, THIS FOMENTED CULTURE WAS
ABSOLUTELY AMPLIFIED BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, BY CASUAL
DISPLAYS OF PIGS IN COP UNIFORMS
BY PRO ATHLETES BY
COLIN KAEPERNICK.
THIS IS SOMEHOW ACCEPTABLE.
ACAB SPRAY-PAINTED EVERYWHERE.
IT BECAME EXCEPTED CULTURALLY TO
BE ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU CAN BE NEUTRAL THAT'S WHAT
YOU CHOOSE.
THE DOWNRIGHT OUTRAGEOUS VIOLENT
RHETORIC HAS HAD REAL-LIFE
CONSEQUENCES AND WHILE WE CAN'T
LAY BLAME AT PARTICULAR PEOPLE'S
MOUTHS, RHETORIC DOES MATTER.
WORDS MATTER.
ACTIONS MATTER.
THAT'S WHAT'S LED TO THIS
CURRENT CULTURE IN THESE
IRRETRIEVABLE DEATHS.
>> Jackie: AND INACTION
MATTERS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
EVERYTHING'S OKAY AND WE ARE NOT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM IN
THIS COUNTRY, THAT'S ALSO A
PROBLEM.
DEMOCRATS DOUBLING DOWN ON
DEFUND THE POLICE IS ONE ISSUE.
THE PEOPLE DOING NOTHING IS
ANOTHER ISSUE.
WHAT DO PEOPLE WANT IN THIS
COUNTRY QUESTION LIKE THEY WANT
TO FEEL SAFE.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL, PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE, A FUTURE THAT'S
BRIGHTER THAN YESTERDAY.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS IS BEING
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
SEVERAL ARE ACTUALLY BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO CRIME IT'S BEING TAKEN
AWAY AND WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
OFFICERS, NO ONE WANTS TO BE A
POLICE OFFICER.
WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN THE
POLICE.
YOU CAN PURSUE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM WITHOUT TAKING POWER AWAY
FROM THE POLICE.
COMING TOGETHER AND FINDING THE
MIDDLE GROUND TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THE PROBLEM WITH SOCIETY AND SO
MANY ISSUES AS WE HAVE BECOME SO
EXTREME, SO POLARIZED, SO AT
OPPOSITE ENDS.
REALLY WHO SUFFERS IS YOU, ME,
THE AMERICANS WALKING ON THE
STREET SCARED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN THESE POLICE
OFFICERS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR CHILDREN.
>> Kayleigh: OFFICER LANE AND
FIFTH GRADE WANTED TO BE A
SHERIFF AND HE LOST HIS LIFE
PURSUING THE DREAM.
I WONDER HOW MANY BOYS AND GIRLS
THINK THEY WANT TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER WHEN THEY SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Emily: INSTEAD WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT, COMMANDER IN CHIEF,
WHO SAYS GIVE ME A COUPLE DAYS,
MAN.
WHEN SOMEONE SHOUTED.
INSTEAD OF STANDING BY THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM, INSTEAD OF
ENCOURAGING YOUNG CHILDREN TO
WANT TO SERVE, TO BE THOSE
HEROES IN UNIFORM DAY IN AND DAY
OUT WITH THEIR LIVES IN THE LINE
FOR OUR PROTECTION.
HERE ON THIS COUCH, WE